dans les salles cette semaine
aussi 17 une très jolie comédie
canadienne qui s'appelle la femme de mon
frère réalisé par monia chokri c'est son
premier film
elle est aussi actrice et elle est très
proche de l'univers et d'ailleurs du
personnage de xavier dolan alors très
rapidement c'est une histoire de famille
comédie très réussie très bien joué à 6
percutante avec une l'histoire d'une
fratrie en fait d'un frère et d'une
soeur qui vivent ensemble jusqu'à ce que
le frère rencontre une femme qui n'est
autre que la gynécologue de la soeur
tout ça au milieu d'une famille avec des
parents divorcés qui s'aiment encore qui
vivent à proximité d'un garage d'autres
dans la maison voilà je vous en dis pas
plus mais venez découvrir ce film c'est
vraiment une très belle réussite
il a été très remarquée à cannes cette
année allait bien à bord avec une
mention du jury de la section un certain
regard le dans les salles si cette
semaine aussi 17 le très beau film de
pedro almodovar parle avec elle qui fait
partie du cycle que nous avons
organisées sur le cinéma pedro almodovar
donc en version originale l'histoire de
deux hommes qui se retrouvent dans un
hôpital avec deux femmes qui sont
plongées toutes les dents cobas et des
chirons c'est bouleversant et c'est à
voir
et enfin petite fierté et une grande
joie pour le signer cette nous avons
tenu cette année les trois label art et
essai c'est à dire jeune public
patrimoine et répertoires et recherche
et découverte pour nous en sommes très
heureux
et vous pourrez en profiter dans nos
salles et enfin petite info nous restons
ouverts tout l'été avec nous trois
salles climatisées et vous souhaitons à
tous et à toutes
un très bel été 2019
[Musique]